Speaker 1: Following up on yesterday's story
that former Trump aide and Breitbart propagandist
Stephen Bannon is being indicted again, again
for his build the wall scam.
It has happened yesterday.
Stephen Bannon did indeed surrender to the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office.
He made quite a scene here is Bannon showing
up and he starts screaming and then someone
in the crowd is screaming and it's just a
complete and total mess.
Unidentified: Yeah.
I mean.
Speaker 2: This is irony.
On the very day the mayor of the city has
a delegation down on the border, the first
security people here to try to stop them for
six months.
Speaker 1: So ban and yelling about the border.
A bystander yelling, stop hurting America.
What a mess.
Speaker 2: 60 days.
Take a step back and take some.
Six days in March.
Do you have any idea how many appreciate or
do you agree?
Speaker 1: See Griff there.
I like I have to tell you that I like short
stuff.
Speaker 2: What do you think?
Speaker 1: After two bit, I agree with as
well.
Now, if you don't remember what this is all
about.
Steve Bannon and a guy named Brian Kolfage
were raising money to build their own wall
on the US-Mexico border.
A complete and total absurdity, an obvious
scam, and indeed it was.
Here is just 20 seconds, because this is all
I can take from when they did this wall a
thon.
Speaker 2: Steven K Bannon and Brian Kolfage.
Speaker 3: Welcome back.
This is Stephen K Banner and we're off the
coast of Central Pay in southern France, in
the Mediterranean.
We're on the million dollar yacht now.
Brian Cole Fischer and Brian Cole Fischer.
He took all that money from Build the Wall.
No, we're actually in Sunland Park, New Mexico.
Speaker 1: Well, it turns out that they really
did abscond with the money.
Brian Kolfage did.
And it's beyond parody that this is now where
we are.
Steve Bannon was pardoned by Donald Trump
on the federal charges for this build the
wall scam that pardon presidential pardons
don't apply to state charges.
These are now state charges in the state of
New York.
And here it goes all over again.
One other just really funny note, adding stupidity
to absurdity.
Steve Bannon, when surrendering yesterday,
did yell out Trump one These people are parodies
of themselves.
Speaker 2: Trump one finds their legitimate
this, oh god.
Speaker 1: These people are pathetic.
So we'll follow the trial and there is no
presidential pardon coming this time.
And that will be very interesting
to
see